welcome everyone I'm absolutely
delighted to welcome you all to the
inaugural lecture and the flagship
Frankie lecture series on tidal mapping
as knowing this is a new initiative that
we are debuting this academic year and
have planned a series of exciting
lectures that interrogate what mapping
means today and what it has meant
historically and across disciplines
first of all I would like to thank
several faculty across departments at
Yale who came together last year to help
us flesh out this vision for this series
I would like to thank bill Rankin from
history of science I assure Ramachandran
from comparative literature Laura
Barraclough
from American Studies Raymond Clemens
from the Meineke library Ronald Smith
from geology and geophysics and Rick
Prum from ecology and evolutionary
biology as you can see this is giving
you a flavor of the kinds of disciplines
that are going to engage in our series
before briefly talking about the
resident death for the series I would
like to acknowledge the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Frankie who are in
the audience thank you very much for
your gift that has made all of this
possible so in my own field astronomy
for instance mapping has been the
principal way of knowing and maps of the
sky over time have encoded the state of
our knowledge our conception of cosmos
in fact we are now at a stage when we
have successfully indirectly mapped
invisible entities in the universe in
other fields mapping has often provided
key insights into complex collective
phenomena be it disparities and income
across geographies voting patterns pred
of diseases and visually epistemic
relationships between phenomena that are
helping us disentangle correlation from
causation maps remain deeply meaningful
even as what they encode is rapidly
evolving as part of the series we will
be hearing from distinguished speakers
about mapping various intellectual
terrains and what
mapping has provided us in terms of
construction of new knowledge across
fields mapping the scientific process
itself which is our next dog by Feliz
Frankel will be in October mapping what
computers have taught us will be our
talk in November from Jacques hidari who
heads Google X mapping the genome
mapping the brain mapping languages and
so on so forth so we have an entire year
of monthly exciting talks also we are
required to give you this notice this
event is being recorded and photographed
for educational archival purposes and
including use in print and on the
Internet in other forms of media by
attending this event today you agree to
the possibility of your voice or your
likeness being captured by these means
and use for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby waive any
related right of privacy or publicity
and there will be a reception in room
108 immediately following the event and
we warmly invite all of you to come and
continue the conversation downstairs we
have an absolutely fantastic speaker
very distinguished scholar and
cartographer professor Matthew Edney as
our inaugural speaker this evening I
would now like to invite bill ranking
associate professor of history of
science whose own work has focused on
cartography navigation and relationship
to territory to induce introduced
professor ed new bill thank you Priya
and so it's my great pleasure to
introduce our speaker today Matthew
Edney Matthew is one of the world's
leading scholars on the history of maps
mapping and cartography he has
particular expertise in the 18th and
19th century but I don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that he's one of the
few people who can speak with some real
authority about nearly any aspect of map
history especially in the West so I will
just Matthew here in two different ways
first the official biographical
introduction and then briefly kind of my
own personal reflection on his work so
institutionally Matthew wears to Maine
house he was trained as a geographer
studied under one of the major
historians of mapping of a previous
generation and now he's professor of
geography
oh sure professor of the history of
cartography at the University of
Southern Maine the Osher and his name
chair is connected with the Osher map
library a major map collection that
first brought Matthew to Maine in 1995
and where he's been installed as
Faculty's scholar ever since he has
helped the library to grow exponentially
both in its physical and digital
incarnation since 2005 he's also held a
position at the University of
wisconsin-madison where he directs the
monumental history of cartography
project a multi-decade NSF funded
collaboration to provoke research and
writing from scholars around the world
working on maps and mapping I here it is
just now finishing editing about a
million words on cartography during the
European enlightenment which will be
appearing next year from the University
of Chicago Press Matthew's own
scholarship has wane ranged widely both
within the book centric humanities and
the more article centric realm of
geography his first book mapping an
empire the geographic construction of
British India 1765 to 1843 traced the
history of British attempts to map the
Indian subcontinent mostly as he shows
without the success they had hoped for
his forthcoming book which will here be
hearing a bit more about today is
cartography the ideal and its history
which I won't spoil now with any further
comments he's also published many
influential articles on everything from
the early mapping of New England to
theoretical perspectives on the nature
of mapping to deep dives into the
history of the field our taking this all
together and say that Matthew's work has
been influential for me ever since I
came across it early in graduate school
and the overarching thread that I see
connecting all the various research and
the the quality that has made his work
so helpful even for someone like me
working on the 20th century is that
mapping Matthew shows convincingly that
mapping is not one big thing it's not
something we can talk about in any
monolithic way mapping is many different
things it always has been and always
will be and we should certainly not take
map makers themselves at their word
they claim to know what mapping is or
how it works and actually now having
shared a room with Matthew on a several
occasions here I would say that what
makes these kinds of broad insights
possible is really a dual interest that
he has both in broad theoretical
statements and a kind of deep empirical
devotion to the history of maps and
mapping over several hundred years on at
least three continents so please join me
in welcoming Matthew Benny okay right
thank you
sorry I just suddenly realized I have
hidden my clock over here but there's a
clock right there in front of me so I
need to stop okay
okay so firstly thank you very much to
Korea and to bill for arranging the
lecture series and be inviting me very
pleased to be here at Yale here we go
so as bill said I am among my sins
director of the history of cartography
project at University of Wisconsin we
have six volumes covering all periods
all times volumes one two and three you
can see a certain trend of growth here
for reasons that I can't get into today
all published through 2007 volume six
published on the twentieth century out
of sequence in 2015 and then we've got
four and five volume four on the 18th
century is halfway through copy editing
right now since it's being divided up
into six batches batch for the letter M
is 526 pages typescript by itself and
that's the next one we're going to get
back from the copy editor so it'll be
interesting to see what they do is that
was a slug to get through
volume 9 f15 in the 19th century is
about 93 95 percent submitted and it's
about 40% edited at this point and so
hopefully knocking on wood we will have
that out in 2023 for sure come out late
in 1920 23 for volume 5 again assuming
funding which is always the big question
one of my particular triumphs I managed
to persuade the University of Chicago
Press to put all existing volumes and in
the future volumes of the commitment
online for free public access volumes
one two and three went online in
2011-2012 and volume six went online as
of July 1 of this year so far I kept
like collect six monthly metrics up
through June of 2018 we've had over
three million chapter downloads volumes
1 through 3 a statistic that appears
very prominently in every single grant
application that I do right now much of
the material in today's talk is actually
drawn from the book that bill was just
talking about shakaar cartography the
idea in this history it will have a 2019
date it might appear as early as
December perfect for your Christmas
stockings but probably will appear in
January or February
I just learned today that this image
will be the cover image of the book are
something to show you the cover itself
but it's still winding his way through
approvals at the press and much of what
I'm saying today I'm actually also
written up in various other forms at a
website that I develop largely thanks to
Bill's inspiration open to it I can do
it I can't do anything nearly as good as
bill does on his site so mapping is
process dotnet which is why I'm trying
to work out some ideas leading up to two
or three books down the line
I got big ideas big plans so as Priya
said this is the inaugural lecture in
the Frankie program of mapping as
knowing my TAS today is really basically
to think about this concept what we what
do we mean by mapping and what is
mapping actually entail I'm not going to
speak very much about the various other
topics that are going to be addressed in
this series I just want to talk about
mapping from the point of view of an
interdisciplinary map historian what are
the foundations of this concept of
mapping and what are the hidden
implications of it so having passed
through the puffery this presentation
therefore comprises a review of the
common literal and the figurative
understandings of mapping to case
studies which suggest both of them in
different ways that we can push mapping
too far and both of these case studies
suggest directions for analysis and then
finally a bit more about what I mean is
mapping its stemming from these two case
studies so let's get down to business
literally mapping is taken Jerry to mean
the act of making maps of turning the
world to paper or nowadays to digital
screens this process was implemented on
the title page to Adam Friedrich sirnas
atlas of the electorate of Saxony made
some time before 1742
the great thing about this image and
this is going to be the dust-jacket
image to part 2 of volume 4 of the
history of cartography Mina's published
it has these four vignettes I'm not I'm
ignoring the atmosphere in the middle
that's different sort of skeletal fish
but together these four vignettes talk
about the observation and
measurement and compilation of the
results of those observations into maps
and he seemed very nicely define this
process of mapping in a sort of a naive
kind of way
so in the upper left vignette we have a
stereotypical act of survey of guided
observation from a lofty vantage point
here he is on top of a hill Serna is
almost certainly the guy in the blue
frock coat he's looking through a
circumference er which is a compass with
open alidade sights and he's taking
bearings of various places just down the
hill is his assistant recording the
observations in the notebook but this is
not a strictly algorithmic process in
that siRNAs work is being guided by
these two figures unidentified but
probably locals of some kind of standing
who are pointing out the points of
interest the places of interest the
things that zurna as a surveyor from a
way needs to know about in order to
observe them and of course in the
foreground we have the staff of servants
holding their horses now the situation
is a bit more complex this is actually
part of the process of filling in
details it's not part of the overall
control process the control process is a
very interesting 18th century German
technique where you go up and you have
little paper disks and you put them on a
plate and then you draw lines to all of
your other observation stations and
[Music]
Stroke Geographic process at about 1,000
stations erna drew 2,000 of these paper
circles and then back in the office now
we're in the top right vignette there's
owner of the far right directing this
guy to arrange these paper circles
notice he's got a ruler next to him
that's going to be defined
the scale needs a bit more detail so
this is a process it's very low
precision it's not trigonometrical is
not the high science is a very graphic
pragmatic process but nonetheless is
creating a control network of
triangulation there's then going to
serve as the basis within which you can
then do all the detailed observation the
details either come from the work of the
circumference or on top of the hill or
by measuring itineraries route distances
so here in the foreground we got to go
with a perambulator has a count of the
counts a number of times the wheel
rotates each movie down paths and so on
next to him is a guy holding a chain
very common measurement tool for smaller
distances and for the roads zurna
equipped a carriage you can see up sort
of black rod here that goes from a
counter while he's a mechanism on the
wheel and it connects to a counter in
the cab and sojourner
can barrel down the roads at whatever
high speed you can get on those roads of
those days measuring distances as he
goes you take all this information and
you put them all together here in the
last quote vignette the lower-left and
yet and you can see Cerner again
directing the compilation of all these
measurements within this control network
to make the final map here's as one of
the many maps in this particular Atlas
this is of the crisis of leipzig the
circle leipzig with a very detailed
index of place names on the side all
nicely indexed into the work here is a
particular detail of a county of lactic
and you can see that there are some
roads on there
different kinds of towns and all details
knowledge it's phenomenal work the
starts bibliothèque in dresden has is
all online so you can observe it to your
heart's content
also some other strategies for mapping
in this case an unfinished table of
distances across the electorate so this
is the literal meaning of mapping making
a map controlled systems of measurements
producing a selectively reduced image
that captures the structural essence of
the world for chris board british
establish map maker maps are
concentrations of the real world in
model form my favorite sort of summary
definition of a map maps are depleted
homologs
of the world when everybody captures the
sense of somehow having been reduced you
know at the same time reproducing the
world in these kinds of approaches maps
allow us to see the world to think about
the world to make visible what is
invisible to see new arrangements and
connections to see new routes to see new
pathways that can be followed to
interpolate new data to enable new
actions to create new insights and in
this respect mapping has stood for best
part of the 20th century as a recurring
metaphor for science and maps as
scientific theories whether we're
talking about Steven torment Michael
Polanyi or whoever as Jacob says map
suggests ways of thinking as well as
ways of seeing you know these are really
powerful things
powerful images from this basic sort of
pragmatic standpoint we go from the
literal to the figurative figurative
mapping is essentially when you take a
phenomenon and you treat it as if it was
the world you treated you represent it
as if you're making the 2-dimensional
constructor of some sort we bring not
the world to paper but some phenomenon
to paper whether it's DNA some kind of
future action or as here relationships
this is a gallant geography as Charlie
Withers calls it the famous cut to
Tundra but by Madeline discovery where
she's mapping out the different kinds of
affection in a social relationship
sometimes called the map of love is not
is a map of social interactions and the
different ways different people can
interact a more recent example actually
made to look like a world map is this
what they do 2013 map of the internet
has even drawn on a map projection the
same map projection that National
Geographic Society uses nowadays it has
a scale and even a numeric ratio
representative fraction I'm not quite
sure what the units are though on either
side of that ratio the metaphor works
because we know what mapping is we know
what map making is this process I've
just described is not new I mean people
be making maps this kind of way going
way back when control networks change
the techniques change but the basic
practice of looking at landscape
reproducing it on paper has been very
old but is that actually what mapping is
about
and so as I've suggested let's look at
two maps that start to problematize
there's very entrenched understanding of
mapping as cartography so let's start
with Mark Twain's map of the
fortifications of Paris about which I am
absolutely obsessed I really wanted this
not this map the next map to be the
cover of the book but press wouldn't
have it they like the globe instead so
this is the New York Times new tribute
from 13th of September 1870 if you don't
know the history basically France
declares war on Prussia in July of 1870
by mid-august the Prussians were
besieging the main French Army in Metz
by the 2nd of September or on the 2nd
September they defeated the second
French army at Verdun
Sariah sedan conquering capturing
Emperor luda Napoleon and by
mid-september they're advancing on Paris
and everybody's expecting Paris to be
besieged and of course it is and their
needs to commune and everything else but
Andales miss but in the meantime these
maps appear in this kind of map appears
in New York newspapers
other newspapers in the country and this
map of Paris and is surrounded by this
dead straight line of fortifications
that are clearly meaningless it's just
like a graphic all those fortifications
so Mark Twain then a newspaperman
thought he would satirize it
first things first Twain was a wordsmith
he was not a graphic artist and even
though he worked in the press he
actually cut the wood block for this
himself but he cut it right readings or
when it printed it printed wrong reading
which he then used to his advantage
now in this Twain used standard
cartographic conventions he has double
lines for River
he has crenelated shapes 4/4 little
squares four places and a little
building for a house I mean these are
all fairly standard kind of conventions
but of course he also played with these
conventions here's a town of podunk
which by the 1840s there's a town of
podunk which by the 1840s has already
become the metaphor for places that are
so small and so insignificant it's
actually around here somewhere
that they should never appear on a map
they're not not worthy of appearing on
that here is podunk and he also pleased
with scale so in addition to having all
of Paris you've got an individual fence
line which Twain is going to write about
as being a lynchpin of perusing defenses
against the Prussians and of course
Twain purposefully mixed up the
geography Paris is at the confluence of
not only the sin but the Rhine and the
Erie Canal Paris and Verdun are joined
by Omaha st. cloud Jersey City
down in his French town of insaine at
least one American newspaper assumed
that was been sent Indiana not up in San
Fran's so here we have a counter
argument to mappings knowing mapping to
obscure transforming certainty into
absurdity although I must admit Twain
extends the the joke and says that
readers can stand on VSAT on your head
you can read this properly or use a
mirror so at a trite level Twain's map
stands beyond a limit to mapping is
we've passed the border mapping into
something else but what really excited
contemporary readers and frankly me was
the written text
which came with official commendations
General Sherman wrote for example it is
but fair to say that in some respects it
is a truly remarkable map well general
general grant it is the only map of the
kind I ever saw my favorite the everyman
John Smith who was writing saying his
wife has been afflicted with freckles
one side of this map and she is now
cured she only has the convulsions now
these these these commendations they get
reprinted in newspapers very quickly and
in fact I found them being quoted six
nine months later when they really as as
fast as anything in go viral in the
nineteenth century these things went
viral and for me the kicker is this
statement right at the beginning the
above map explains itself a few months
later
Mark Twain reproduced the map in the
galaxy the forerunner of the Atlantic
Monthly where he added more to the
commentary and in particular coming down
here we said strangers to me keep
insisting that this map does not explain
itself one person came to me with
bloodshot eyes and harassed who look
about him and shook the map in my face
and he said he believed I'm some new
kind of idiot this emphasis on the idea
by Twain the idea that maps should be
self explanatory is the crux to meet for
me of the overall significance of this
work the emphasis shifts a satire from
mocking the map to mocking the common
assumptions about what maps are supposed
to be and in this respect it is the
first critique that I've been able to
identify of the new ideal of cartography
this ideal is a body of idealizations
that developed in a very haphazard
manner there are all sorts of reasons
over the course of the 19th century
the final developments especially with
the rise of personal mobility post date
this map so tween satoori is quite early
and not really effective the ideal
entails a whole series of convictions
that define the nature of all maps in
our everyday conceptions there are all
maps of pictures of the world made by
the same kind of empowered vision that
they seem to give readers that all maps
are necessarily about guiding people
that they are for navigation and that
they function independently of any
larger technological system which
they're actually embedded try using a
road map by itself without looking at
road signs when you're driving down the
highway you just got to do it it entails
the ideal entails a series of
convictions that all maps are the same
that all maps are reductions of the
world regardless of the reasons of which
they were made and that the quality and
quantity of that reduction is measured
by a single value the representative
fraction in numerical ratio we have then
a single endeavor of cartographic this
is what defines mapping in common
parlance in this respect all Maps appear
the same whether we're talking about a
17th century world map in 19th century
early 20th century city plan
choreographic map based on medieval
knowledge published in the 15th century
Chinese topographical map from the late
20th century or a marine chart from the
17th century all of these works
normalized as depictions of spatial fact
maps that don't fit the requirements the
ideal derided as map like objects or car
toys in German this particular 1930s
pictorial map of Ohio that I stumbled
across in the
yesterday this calls itself a cartograph
the back formation of cartograph is
being is used for fairly loves fitting
extensively today by people who are
working with that say Native American
Maps or Cisco diagrams that have a
spatial dynamic but are not real Maps so
we call cartograph Nicholas Cage in
national treasure referred to the map of
the on the back of the Constitution as a
cartograph for example now we can begin
to see the ideal at work in the second
case study which details an image that
people have assumed many times is the
oldest map known in the world
so in central Turkey on the Konya Plains
is a settlement called also one called
Casa del Hyuk here it is a mound looking
eastwards
it was dug in the sixties by James
millet and more recently by Ian Hodder
very famous archaeologist Mehta
publishes results in a series of
articles and Anatolian studies and a
1967 book the site is as after Meadows
excavation is fascinating it is all
private structures there are no large
spaces for public buildings there are no
roads running through it it comprises
about 18 distinct archaeological layers
dating from about seven and a half
thousands BCS or nine and a half
thousand years ago to about 5500 BC a
seven and a half thousand years ago at
any one time it had a population of
about five to seven thousand people so
fairly substantial here's an artist's
impression which at least gives you the
sense of how access to the houses was
done people walked over the rooftops
and then you drop down through a hatch
into individual rooms houses storerooms
whatever they are okay now here's a plan
from the 1964 report for the 63 filled
season showing one section of one level
and in room 14 of this level Mellott
found and his team found a very
interesting mural that sort of is on one
wall then wraps around the corner a bit
here's the photograph from
mellotts report you can sort of see this
design on the wall now this is a wall
that's been whitewashed repeatedly so
they were taking off the whitewash and
they found this thing and there's a
further you can see all these dots over
here there's another feature here it is
removed and in the museum under
different lighting conditions and again
you can see the series of these blocks
of color and then there's their sort of
feature up here with dots on much
clearer if you look at it in the modern
reconstruction at the Museum on site so
there it is series of these blocks and
then this feature up here originally
minute and his team saw this because oh
it's just like everything else that we
see at this site this site has many many
many murals featuring repeated geometric
designs it also has a large number of
ball heads a large number of models of
leopards and a large number of things
that'll sort of look like leopard skins
but later
melih and his map maker grace Huxtable
went wait a minute it's just like our
Maps and so in the published 1964 report
and then in the book of 67 they argue
that because of the similarity you only
have to compare figure 11 which is their
outline of the archeological dig with
Huxtables redrawing of the mural that
it's possible that this is a map what
then is the strange double peak element
at the top for Mehmet it's just like the
mountains are a number of turn peaked of
volcanic volcanic mountains this is the
mountain of Hasan door the merit thought
was the source of the obsidian that you
find at the neolithic settlement of
saturday york for knives and mirrors and
things like that only one problem
when you actually look at house and door
when you can see it from satella high
york is actually other way around and
this starts to expose a series of
problems with this interpretation the
key here is worked by one was stephanie
mies in 2006 again published Antonian
studies who argued that the volcanoes
are wrong
besides which is not the source of your
pacinian but moe most importantly Mies
was arguing why should Neolithic
townspeople have made a map in the first
place and there are lots of possible
reasons especially around rituals and
religion and so forth but if they did
make a plan of the settlement why did
they make it in such a way that it looks
just like a modern archaeological plan
which of course is just the walls with
none the coverings or anything else like
that
so by and large most people have said
yep it's not a map Peters argument is
persuasive done a map but some people
and this is what intrigues me some
people are arguing it is a map the
assists that is a map so another limit
to mapping then is over interpretation
but why people insist on over
interpreting it is another matter now
under the ideal map making is strictly
an individual and intellectual activity
there's a cognitive function and that
the map itself the process of making the
map is externalizing creating
externalized expression of what's in the
cartographers mind so we can find very
frequently comments like well let me
just back up there is a persistent
conflation and confusion of basic
concepts the cognitive map ie the
spatial schema that we have in our heads
which we call cognitive map but map
there is only a metaphor because we
don't actually know what neurons are
getting there but the way that our
spatial knowledge is remembered and
structured in our minds is not like a
map so we've got cognitive map then
there's sketch map and mental map sketch
maps are anything you draw mental map is
when academics bring together a whole
bunch of people's conceptions or they've
they've got through ask them to make
sketch maps or asking them to explain
verbally what they think about spaces
and they then make maps from them but
mental map in particular is consistently
used has been the best part of a century
to equate directly what's in the mind to
what's on the paper so we find
statements like I map therefore I am by
Katherine harm or the urge to map is a
basic enduring human instinct to map in
terms of to produce a
spatial concept in the brain yes
absolutely
but is the external expression in Inked
to the individual so Keith Clark who is
a well Keith Clark and Danny darling or
both big-name at Lehman cartographers
from either side of the Atlantic both
argue that the Neolithic mural satify
oak is indeed a map in Clark in
particular argues that it looks like a
map therefore it is a map it looks the
mural looks like our Maps
looks like the site it is and it's been
some public commentary about the volcano
he looked like a volcano therefore it is
a volcano therefore the whole thing is a
map Clark
actively misinterprets me to say that
meters arguing that them that the people
in 8000 years ago in Neolithic town who
are fully cognitively developed Homo
sapiens just like you and I don't have
the capacity to make a map meat doesn't
argue that at all but because Clark has
this conflation of mapmaking with the
mental with the cognitive map then he
interprets Mises saying that and then he
notes the states right up front actually
one of his assumptions proof that Homo
sapiens co-evolved with maps as external
cognitive ace navigation and sort as
possible even probably exists so
implicit in all this is the sense of the
structure of the map I have
flipped my slides sorry implicit in this
is that the structure of the map is a
direct expression of how the
individual's cognitive construct is made
which leads to essentializing statements
that people X think about space in this
way and only this way assess especially
when it comes down to non-western
peoples and also to degree Western women
this is an image from a book which has
tons of tons of pictures of men doing
things with maps while women look on
there's only two images in which women
are actually agents doing things one is
there the women who are putting the maps
the National Geographic maps into the
magazines and this is the other one and
is a white woman who is interpreting
Inuit maps based on a u.s. Coast chart
or Canadian coastal chart so the liminal
position of the wound in terms of
Western mapping is able to interpret
this non-western mapping Malcolm Louis
in volume 1 and history of cartography
argued the topological mapping done by
in visions people's prehistoric peoples
indicates that their cognitive
development we talked about 30 grown
adults was at the pre-operational stage
of jean piaget scale which would put
them about 2 to 7 years old mental age
and of course PA jays scaling of
childhood development of Western
children is based in part on
imperialistic ethnographies of other
peoples especially having Guineans
who seem to be behaving childlike and so
their topological maps at therefore
childlike in it we get this incredible
conflation of concepts
Western society has been essential eyes
in a spatial production in the same way
there are a lot of people who have
argued that there is only one way in
which Westerners think about space this
is in for example a conception but used
by Frederic Jamison and David Harvey as
they're trying to talk about postmodern
culture as a manifestation of late
industrial capitalism in which they both
argue that there is a Western
cartography for Jamison and develops and
Middle Ages with marine charts with
Jamison is with bespoke introduction of
perspective of vision Renaissance but
there that this model of rationality
ends that his model of rationality ends
when late industrial capitalism changes
how we have to act and they both start
talking about living in cities and urban
places Jamison says we had to do this
now Harvey says it happened in the 18th
in the 19th century with the rise of
cubism and stuff but either way they're
grounded in essentializing arguments a
basement bad history so anyway the
salient point for me is that everybody
in our society makes maps in different
ways with different spatial conceptions
based on different functions that we do
every one of us will be moving through
space walking around New Haven we think
topologically it's how we think about
media spaces of which we're walking we
have other forms of spatial conceptions
which we learn from maps among other
things so as between we need to be aware
that the ideal of cartography exists and
we need to basically ditch it and break
away from it as I like to say there's no
such thing as cartography and this is a
lecture about it don't use the word
cartography it's just the idealization
and from the catalytic analysis we have
to be aware that there's a difference
between cognitive schemas that we have
in individual minds and then the
expressions that we make and there's
expressions that mapping is a social and
semiotic process necessarily so so we
can look at this whole array of maps and
we can start saying but we've got marine
mapping mapping me by Mariners for
Mariners you look carefully there is
very little content inside the lens all
the emphasis is on the oceans button
systematic mapping whether it's
topographical hydrographic at astral
what have you there's all geared to
state formation and exertion of state
control and so on chorographical mapping
regional mapping is all about creating
sensors regional identity whereas times
urban planning or this in this case is
actually engineering mapping is about
building things and maintaining the
physical structure infrastructure of our
world and then there's world and cosma
graphical mapping all of which are about
where are we
feasibly the world reasonably the divine
and how everything fits together each of
these kinds of maps represents a
particular mode of mapping and we can
look at look I've I'm now 214 modes of
different kinds of spatial concepts
different kinds of mapping the
identification of a mode is fairly crude
we can talk about for example mappings
of place mappings that are about
defining places defining the uniqueness
of a given place in this instance we
have fortifications mapping but we also
have the kind of wayfaring guidance
mapping which can be verbal as much as
it can be graphic and so on
world and geographical mapping entail a
variety of discourses that variously
weave the factual with the political
yeah and edit bodas to hemispheres of
the world the european hemisphere is
centered on berlin where he's based you
see the same maps made by the french oh
no - based on Paris in London
Britain's based in London and so on but
they get more fun Ornstein A's 16th
century Quarter forum in which the world
is the heart of the cosmos is the heart
of faith or we have the overly political
propaganda stick mapping so common in
the 20th century both from the left and
from the right moats if you pursue them
strongly enough give way to more precise
threats of discourse know the radical
world mapping as opposed to atlas world
mapping as opposed to the world maps you
get in educational books and so on and
you can even if you're lucky enough
determine particular discourses in
Portland Maine up to 1866 when half the
city burnt down there is a very clear
local practice of mapping the city for
people in the city so North is actually
you can tell by the North era North is
actually up here in the top right corner
but we show the peninsula of the city
across the base to maximize the page
title in the back Cove compass rose and
then the legend in this case a graphic
legend of the buildings in the four
river which is the port and you go to
South Portland over here well then Cape
Elizabeth you see this structure
repeated over again through the 19th
century when portlanders are mapping
Portland for themselves but when people
from outside from away come in
they've got some national engineering
training I think all we need to have
standards with North at the top and all
of a sudden the peninsula goes diagonal
and you've got lots of extra space to be
filled with various things and so on so
there's a very particular discourse very
well clearly bounded both in time and in
in social community doing that kind of
work takes a lot of work so it's best to
work at the modes to begin with then we
can drill down a bit so ultimately we
can say there are highly diverse variety
of processes by which spatial complexity
is understood and communicated within a
given community one community can
sustain multiple different ways of
mapping I should say spatial complexity
is my shorthand because frankly if it's
not complex why are people bothering to
communicate it to think about it twain's
absurdist map is necessarily understood
within the dispersed community of
newspaper readership in the late later
19th century us and actually it failed
to meet that readerships discursive
expectations the readership really
didn't like the map many of the
commentary when the commentary gets
reprinted over and over again across the
eastern United States it's frequently
prefaced by saying this is far more
funny than the map which might meet just
an excuse because they can't reproduce
the map but it's the commentary that
persists well beyond the Prussians have
actually laid siege to Paris and is no
longer a newsworthy event for mapping to
happen and this is the limit to mapping
there needs to be a community a
regulated Network which has established
semiotic patterns within that network we
can have mapping as a construction
spatial complexity we can have the
creation of maps whatever format they
take whether
graphic verbal physical installations in
the landscape combinations thereof I
should also say there is no such thing
as cartographic language academic
cartographers love to say so back
holographic language no it's much more
complex than not a problem of bringing
together multiple sets of codes of a
meaning without that social semiotic
system you don't have maps
you only have marks thank you
[Applause]
the volcano is is the secondary item the
at least in terms of the argumentation
you've got to accept that the graphic
outline the graphic pattern is a map of
the town and then you can start
interpreting this shape as a volcano and
if you and a lot of the puppet
commentary
there's been a couple of news user
reports about the last couple years how
stressed the volcano is saying it must
be the volcania volcania was real
Hassan door did erupted during the
lifetime of the settlement and is a
recent discovery and probably close to
the making of the mural therefore this
mural shows a volcano
but you're still missing that point of
semiosis of interpret and and so what
happens is the diagram is interpreted of
the mural is interpreted according to
our conceptions of what a map should be
not what good archaeological practices
which is his as a shape his a his a
mural less interpreted in the context of
all the other murals that are on that
site and you do it that way it's not a
map and that's not a volcano so I
completely blown off everybody can't see
it the light
no I really like the distinction that
separation of that from I found that is
mediated by understanding of symbols so
for example would this mean that we
cannot really interpret three
presentations so for example there's a
raging debate about cave art so can we
actually interpret something about the
cognitive imagination of the people who
made that art and read into that that
the things that matter to them well no
[Laughter]
I know the my psychological friends
would hate me for this how do we know
what this is I was trying to find a
sunset that slide to end and I couldn't
for today it's not my laptop this is a
local landmark in Bar Harbor up in Mount
Desert Island in Maine and it's a big
moose that sits on top of a restaurant
down near the waterfront that
illuminates at night if you don't know
that that's the moose right so yeah part
of the other problem is people because
there's an insistence within the idea of
cartography that maps are material this
is a whole different topic we don't in
the I under the idea we don't really
care about how material the map is all
the work of art or whatever we just know
that it exists and so analysis is
therefore split into map production that
creates this thing and then map use then
uses this thing any of the most critical
scholars keep this divide which
immediately breaks down makes it
impossible to think in terms of how maps
are circulating how maps being read and
understanding massive semiotic systems
so even those academic scholars who
study mapping has a similarly process
they store don't want to think of it as
a linguistic process because they think
it's you make the map thing but we step
back and say that mapping is both
there's a was both in cooperative and in
scripted to use an older mycological
sense in cooperative in a sense the mean
is incorporated in acts in performances
in rituals as opposed to being inscribed
in some way either on the landscape you
know you know math or whatever you know
on a stone on a piece of paper if you
think of mapping as as a nice immunity's
as being I think cooperative or in
script if then the the way that we think
about the map completely changes and we
don't have a thing the single material
object we have a single material object
in circulation being held being used I
got that slide of people who are working
with a map in the field as opposed to
looking at things so a map this part of
the world property plans the legal
defining marker of property is not the
map it's not the meets and bounds
description in the legal records
it's the monuments placed in the ground
that differentiate somehow lines and
between them so a property plan in terms
of the map is just this sketch of a
property boundary maybe some other
features but the key thing is is that in
actual use in how people relate to this
both in terms of producing and consuming
what's really important are the marks in
the ground that physical installations
and also the ceremonies that we do
around those marks we've missed it is in
the spring there's a Roman holiday
called terminalia which is the holiday
of the god terminus who is the God of
boundaries and in Roman tradition major
boundary markers were actually altars to
the guard terminus and so there you go
around on that day and you perform
certain rites at the altars that are the
property boundaries between this tribe
and the neck
drive which is sort of no different from
every three years a selectman of every
town have to meet up and they go around
the town boundaries to make quite sure
they are all utterly clear and everyone
knows what they are
that's a mapping based on memory based
on performance maybe with a bit of data
in the graphic form to help but unless
you know this the the context and the
largest semiotic system linguistic
system if you want then you can't
actually understand what these guys are
doing so cave art I think you can if you
have enough instances of the art you can
certainly know and now analyze them as
figures
that's a oxen as a deer as an eye this
what-have-you but as a recent thing
right from a cave in South Africa a very
small shard with ochre lines on it and
they're saying this is the oldest piece
of art well yes it's the oldest piece of
somewhere some human has scratched lines
on a stone but it says a teeny little
fragment about the size of my thumbnail
how do we know it's art in the way that
we think of art how do we understand
this as the guy once was painting his
face and just rubbed his fingers on the
stone as a way to get rid of the excess
ochre so he didn't have ochre flavored
meat when he went at the party I don't
know when this is the problem with
ideology and makeup stuff the cows come
home bill
yep and the other investment something's
about culture and cultural ideas but I'm
already mine and I wonder if you could
go a little further in the direction
that you think about how this talk would
connect to having brain mapping the
genome etc cuz I get talks about
somebody saying try to of course blind
see what I'm talking about before the
real map and these other things and so
there's ways that I knew you answer that
by talking about it here enormous
positive social practices creating these
things and then you also give us this
idea of the spatial complexity so the
question is what how do you know the
limits of something that is speaking so
a social network can be mapped in a
certain way at the content as a space
[Music]
so how do we know the limits of space
well I think I mean what you're really
asking is the boundary between the
literal and metaphorical meanings of
mapping and I think in terms of what any
also just back up there are two reasons
why we won't go into math and being in
stuff one because I just don't know
enough about it is one of those topics
that I have like the American Revolution
well my work in colonial America ends in
1765 because I don't want to get
involved in and literature around
revolution it's just too big it's too
complex
the DNA is one of those things in that
sense secondly there's always as weird
element to me that historians of science
don't really get cartography you're one
the very few does and so you read you
know for pointing for history cartago in
the 18th century we went through various
books on the history of science in the
18th century and there's nary a map in
there and there's no hint of cartography
in a few book few specialized books you
get people talking about mapping and
stuff and how it relates to counting and
forest management and stuff but
cartography as a whole is treated as
being utterly problematic and so you can
look at those wonderful books like the
culture of diagram where is all about
the concept of diagram what is a diagram
how two diagrams work how two people
constructed complex diagrams to explain
things and there's not a reference to
mapping in
Oh Maps cartography whatever somehow
diagrams and maps are somehow different
so in terms of this question in terms of
the the boundary point between real and
metaphorical which I really have no
interest in policing as far as I'm
concerned if there is a phenomenon that
you can treat as having multi dimensions
because you've got two or three five two
or three data variables and so okay they
make one X make one Y make one Z may be
issues of standardizing your data or
whatever and then you can start using
mapping data mapping practices or the
conceptions of mapping to help you date
but I have we analyzed the data is that
already I mean anyway answering what
you're trying to get but then there's
also different so one thing I didn't get
into is that different kinds of mapping
are supported by different kinds of
geometry so it's not just geometrization
there's a lot of people have argued that
modern cartography began in the
Renaissance where the geometrization of
daily life and yeah but they're not
really clear about what can't really
mean by geometrization in practice in
how people actually implemented
geometrical concepts in different ways
so your property surveyor who's going
out in the land and doing various things
of brown boundaries treating waters flat
doing distances directions in ways that
sort of look like Euclidian geometry
but never ever amount anything is for
more as official as Euclidean geometry
cosmography people interested in the
earth this relationship to the cosmos
working with latitude longitude which
are Kozma graphical coordinate systems
that have been imposed after Aristotle
on to the earth and that don't
necessarily that a specifically for
spherical object how the Flat Earth of
the lands of air and the church and the
curved earth of the cosmos come together
really is until the 18th mid 18th
century popularized after 1790 in these
big statewide surveys that seemed to be
the basis for the modern idea of
cartography it creates what I'm calling
a projective geometry it looks like
Cartesian and all sorts of people talk
about infinite extensibility of
Cartesian space ya know because within
the discourse of mapping we know the
world is curved in on itself is a closed
three-dimensional object so when you're
mapping the earth before cha Saunders
purse nobody was really thinking about
making maps of infinite space and expose
the x and y coordinates go off to
infinity this purse who gets into this
whole kick about repeating projections
and how they can be repeated in all
directions of that infinity that then
introduces into mathematics this sense
of infinite planes that can be applied
to maps and then people think different
directions I have no idea what I'm
saying
away from my hands around up here
[Applause]
[Music]